I got follow up here Oh since we were
talking about acquaintances last time
and friends and relationships yeah I
wish I would have had this article from
Fast Company because I think it's really
good advice now I'd like to append it a
little bit but I like to talk to you
about this article it's called the
science of why we talk too much
hmm and how the shut up man this is some
advice I could certainly intake well and
let's talk about that so the the
subtitle of this is our brains are wired
to reward us for talking about ourselves
but droning on about yourself is a
horrible way to make a good impression
and I would just say it's a horrible way
to make friends you make meaningful
relationships to just drone on and on
about ourselves do can I tell you like
and I'm guilty of doing this but one of
the one of the things that I don't want
to say like makes me not want to be
friends with someone but it turns me off
from the conversation or from an
interaction is when I'm meeting someone
for the first time and I'm telling them
like a story about like whatever it may
be and then your trip to Cancun yeah my
trip to Cancun that and then and they're
just trying to connect yeah like they're
not trying to do anything mean right but
it's like they'll cut me off and then
they'll tell me about the French trip to
Cancun and like not let me finish my
story like I don't know why but this
happens to be like but I'm also guilty
of doing that sometimes right but it's
but just here to this article's point of
yes like talking about yourself
especially interrupting someone while
they're talking about their self to talk
about yourself yeah not a good way to
make friends yeah not a good way to make
a first impression or a lasting well you
can make a first impression it's not a
good first impression right yeah so
here's I'll read a bit of an excerpt
that we have a discussion around a Ryan
you probably talk too much and there was
a good reason for that science says that
humans being social animals are
programmed to use communication as a
vital tool to survive and thrive this
wouldn't be a problem except for the
fact that science also tells us that our
favorite subject to discuss is ourselves
hmm people spend 60% of their
conversations talking about themselves
80% when chatting on social media so
there's a nice disparity there think
about that Wow and it's it's one of the
reasons that I make sure
or that when I'm when I tend to write
anything that has to do with advice I'm
writing usually in the the plural third
person I'm writing about we here's our
problem as consumers are our problems as
human beings or whatever as opposed
saying you you you you blaming other
people right we're saying me me me me
look how great I am me me me me me but
here's our problem here's how we can fix
it right and then of course I'll often
tell it through my own lens like here's
the story I have but only if it serves
the greater good it's easier for me to
to just blather on and maunder on
endlessly about myself but it doesn't
serve the greater good then we're just
wandering on right so uh 80% of the
chatting on social media the reason
research was found was that it just
feels good so much so that Harvard
psychologists discovered that
individuals were willing to give up
money for the opportunity to disclose
information about themselves huh so
again you're willing to give up money
just so you have the opportunity to
disclose more information about
yourselves
hey and there's there's also basically
people are willing to pay to talk about
themselves yes exactly and there's a
link to a study that Harvard did here
well I mean think about actually think
about social media yeah they're
gathering all that information on you
like people know when they use Facebook
like there they are
their privacy is being invaded but
that's the price they pay to be
masturbatory yes I need to be able to to
you have this digital soapbox from which
I can just mount my nonsense yeah and I
think we're all we're all culpable it's
not to some extent of course question
then is like how can we rein it in
absolutely unfortunately this propensity
to pontificate is at odds with our
collectively dwindling attention spans
which has been measured between as many
as 59 seconds to as few as eight seconds
so our attention span these days is
somewhere around 8 seconds it makes me
sick man because I'm guilty of that dude
absolutely like it is it's yeah this is
a
that it is a problem did you see Tim
Cook the other day Tim Cook Apple guy
yeah he I hear they're announcing
something about how we can stop being
distracted with our our telephones yeah
he was like going on this he just
basically was talking about how he
spends too much time on his phone and um
yeah I was just interesting to see the
CEO of Apple say hey you're I'm on my
phone too much that means that there are
a lot of other people who were probably
on their phone too much right and like
this guy who sells phones it's funny cuz
like I've never really had an opinion
about him but like what it's kind of
like you know oh at Patagonia when
they're like you don't need this jacket
yeah it's like it's a really it's it's a
great marketing because it seems honest
I don't know if he's being you know yeah
if he's doing it for the marketing or
not well you you can mark it honestly
too right I'm sure the whole advertising
I said I wrote a few months back was
sort of about that like there are ways
to promote yourself honestly to try to
help other people and that can actually
help help you make money along the way
and some hopefully amant my great hope
here is because Apple isn't Facebook or
or Google where all of their attention
or where attention is their currency to
a to a great extent with Apple it's more
about the the hardware than it is the
software right yeah and so maybe they
can they can manufacture the hardware in
a way I think you just like accidentally
like burned Apple it's not so much about
the software as much as it's the hard
way well no I mean they recognize that
that they're the money they make is from
selling hardware Google doesn't make
money from selling hard work and and
Facebook doesn't make money from selling
hard work I think both companies would
like to just like Apple would like to
make money from selling software but the
software they sell is essentially free
right it comes with their hardware right
and so when I when I look at when I look
at a company like Apple maybe they can
solve some problems and they can make
some money along the way doing so in
that problem with us right now is this 8
second attention span right yeah so
let's see it was good get back a few
seconds next is a barrage of information
from both verbal and digital sources the
ideal conversation should be total a
total give-and-take with each person
speaking about 50% of the time that
means staying
half of the time a tough but influential
to outweigh that means staying quiet
half of the time a tough but influential
tool for business all there's a link
there to something called a tool for
business as Peter Bergmann notes in the
Harvard Business Review silent silence
is a great a silence is a greatly
underestimated source of power and
silence we can hear not only what is
being said but also what is not being
said and silenced it can be easier to
reach the truth I think ultimately I
that there are some Zen koans there
about silence being the ultimate truth
or something like that but sometimes we
get really uncomfortable and I get it
with especially for like on a podcast or
something you don't want I mean you can
pause for dramatic effect and there's
some radio hosts who do that really well
where you turn on the radio and you're
like is this just dead air and all of a
sudden you hear them talk right you're
getting ready to change the channel like
they they've mastered that dramatic
pause but on a podcast sometimes I'm
just looking for the next thing to fill
the fill to fill but the truth is in our
day-to-day conversations the other other
167 hours a week that we have we should
practice a lot more silence for
listening right yeah and so yes Allen's
is definitely an underestimated source
of power to ensure that you're giving
your conversation partner equal time and
learning as much as you can
Marc Golson a business psychiatrist says
it's important to pay attention to the
three stages of speaking to other people
and these were the tips I thought would
help with the the acquaintances /
friends / adjust relationships in our
lives
number one the business stage on task
relevant and concise so so being
especially if you're wanting to interact
with someone stay on task be relevant
and be six I see the concise the the
succinct or concise the the the old
saying brevity is the soul of wit
mmm-hmm and that is true in writing when
we're communicating Seth Godin wrote
something recently about throat clearing
and how unnecessary it is as some of
them are teaching in my my writing class
for years so how to write better writing
classic the one of the worst things
about blog post
they could start two or three paragraphs
later there's all this throat clearing
of I am really sorry they have to sing
and yeah I haven't written in two weeks
I'm really sorry about that and it's
like no no no get to the point but
that's that's even more true and in
these conversations that that we're
having let me get to the point every
time I've seen the blog posts or a
newsletter something come through and it
starts off with an apology like never
have I been like I'm so glad they said
I'm sorry I'm so glad they apologized
for X Y I mean it was speaking directly
towards what you said about oh I haven't
posted in a couple weeks or even posted
in a while they're in my inbox I
obviously want to read them yeah so you
know it's I don't need an apology but
yeah I totally agree and by the way I
probably because I have so many other
things going on I probably didn't notice
anyway if anything I'm glad you didn't
post and you took your time to write
something that was meaningful right
posted just spamming me yeah thanks for
not just putting content out there yeah
yeah cuz that's offensive right just
being a content generation machine no
one wants that in their inbox if that
happens while you're gonna unsubscribe
right now if you just keep like getting
spammed by someone you're like oh this
isn't adding value anyway anyway now
here's the there are there a lot of
musicians I subscribed to in my inbox
and I like getting updates even if I
find out they're going on tour in
Indiana and Ohio and Michigan like it's
cool for me to see like a little off
date from Andy Davis yeah and oh that's
cool he's doing something like that so I
don't mind something like that that's
not spamming your promo me it just it
too overly promo week it just tells me
what's going on in his sort of life Tori
now if you were to send me reminders
every day that he was going to
Indianapolis I'll be like what are you
doing right and so there is that fine
line you want to be able to communicate
without beating them over the head and
that goes back to this first point stay
on task relevant and concise second
point is the feel-good stage so one so
wonderful and tension-relieving for you
you don't even notice the other person
is not listening so this is kind of a
problem right where you you or I or
anyone we just start like I have to get
this information out
I'm this I'm this bottle of carbonated
information and as soon as I pop at the
top
it's just squirts everywhere yeah it's
that champagne celebration of it's an
explosion of information and and it
feels good to you but it's bad because
they don't even notice the other person
is not listening
I'm just bounding spouting about it have
you ever been talking you all of a
sudden you notice like oh they're like
they've got the dead stare oh dude as
soon as someone you're not listening as
soon as someone like breaks eye contact
with me mmm and I keep me in the middle
of a story if they break eye contact and
they're looking at their phone or you
know they're looking off in the distance
they're looking at girl walking by like
I just stopped the story and half the
time they don't ask me to finish maybe
the other half sound that we like oh
could you finish that story and I will
finish it but yeah 50% of the time I'm
like oh I've lost your attention and
this story is pointless isn't it it's
funny you say that I'm trying to think I
think it was Raymond Carver the short
story writer who said in order to find a
good short story what I'll do is I go
talk to his friends like he'll go to
dinner with his friends or lunch with
his friends mmm and tell the first half
of the story
yeah and then he'll just trail off of
something else and that he knows the
story's good if people come back say hey
back to that one story you were telling
though can you finish that he knows like
yeah I can finish okay lay yeah I can
finish that and then I can write this is
interesting not just with me but with
other people exactly so just be and then
so another tip from another writer David
Foster Wallace he would he would tell
his students that you are both you're
both simultaneously more interesting and
less interesting than you think and his
biggest challenge as a teacher was
trying to convince his students that
they were more interesting they had more
interesting stuff to write about and
they were also less interesting to your
trip to the grocery store to shop for
oranges probably isn't interesting but
there is something about that that might
be interesting the way that I would
reframe that is there's something about
that that might serve the greater good
there's some sort of lesson there yeah
you and I we were on tour 2014 we wrote
about a story about oranges about there
are bruises we bought this bag of Oran
backseat of your Corolla yeah and the
the shot put a link to that in the show
notes if you would podcast Sean it seems
so long ago it was four years ago but it
seems like a lifetime ago yeah and it
was called there will be bruises but the
the story wasn't about shopping for
oranges right right it was about the the
bruises that we were taking on tour it
was a metaphor yeah exactly and so
there's something interesting there but
it's probably not the thing that you
find to be interesting right yeah and
then the third stage of the conversation
he lists here is the off track attempt
to recover stage the off track attempt
to recover stage rather than rien
gauging by listening the usual impulse
is to talk even more an effort to regain
their interest so to see the
aforementioned Harvard results and so I
think that's truly where as I uh I know
I I find especially with people who I
find to be way more interesting in me
than me like I think back to we've done
two podcast now with Rob Bell and the
thing that I wish would have happened
there is I would have I would have
heeded this advice which I knew this
advice I would have heated it more I'd
just shut up and listen more and allow
more talking ask the appropriate
questions that are that are short enough
that like just allow me to get out of
the way all right
instead of feeling the need to re-engage
by by talking and more instead of
listening right mm-hmm
goostin writes that he too was guilty of
this even after writing a book called
just listen that's when coach and NPR
radio host Marty Marty NIM Marty NIM Co
told him that he needed to start
practicing what he preaches
holy moly you guys you're being on PR
they're like hey practice what you
preach you're you wrote a book called
just listen you know what you need to
just listen this is a great lake example
of how none of us are perfect man right
in like that there is not the perfect
conversationalist there's not a perfect
minimalist you know I think this whole
journey for me I don't know about you
Josh but for me it's not about being
perfect it's not about having like the
perfect amount of stuff as much as
building really good habits in my life
and being able to talk about how I can
overcome these for the lack of a better
word these likes these these sins that I
am committing to like to have less and
less since it makes me think about that
you know more wins and losses it's not
about just winning all the time as much
as it is about yeah being writing a book
about being a good conversationalist
and and you know someone calling you out
on it you can say yes like that's why I
wrote the book because I too struggle
with this and this is how I deal with it
exactly yeah but for me my life is
perfect because I do have the right
number of things right what number is
that they're perfectly organized I can't
tell you them you have to buy my book
I'm gonna reveal it the 10 steps to have
the perfect amount of things I want to
be you when I grow up yeah so let's see
nemco offered the following traffic
light strategy to rein in the chatter
you get a green light during the first
20 seconds your listener is liking you
as long as your statement is relevant to
the conversation and hopefully in
service of the other person so the first
20 seconds sort of the intro right you
get the green light and all of a sudden
it's like okay you have 20 seconds to be
really succinct you know they call this
an elevator pitch in some places right
so so what can I do to present the most
relevant things sometimes I think that's
just asking a question because you can
do that in way less than twenty seconds
and it opens up the floor for the other
person allows you to listen and all of a
sudden you seem like a great
conversationalist
yeah when you ask a good quality
question absolutely the yellow light is
the next 20 seconds now the risk is
increasing that the other person is
beginning to lose interest or think
you're long-winded so if you're beyond
20 seconds there so okay unless you're
really compelling so go back going back
to the Rob Bell example you and I saw
him do a two day event and Laguna Beach
mm-hmm he spoke for nine hours a day for
two days straight
it was incredible and I was like he but
he also knew when to take the
appropriate breaks like two hours
anybody all right let's go take a break
for tacos let's go take a break for
surfing and you're like wait just finish
the point and that was the whole point
like he kept you going there it was like
a 18 hour green light
like
you